that dr fauci would publicly hold
contradictory sides of an important
issue in such a short period of time
calls into serious question both his
judgment and competence
but even more disturbing than his
flip-flop and even more relevant for our
look into fauci's ethics is the reason
he gave for the flip-flop
the critical issue was to save
the masks for the people who really
needed them because it was felt that
there was a shortage of mass
in other words fauci based his advice
not on his scientific opinion but on his
political preferences
fauci did in fact believe that the masks
would provide protection to people in
the middle of the outbreak but he wanted
to save the masks for health care work
we were afraid that that would deter
away from the people who really needed
so he lied to the public about his
actual views regarding the efficacy of
masks
then when the much-feared mask shortage
never materialized fauchi flipped his
position and told the public what he
really thought the deceit being a sort
of noble lie for the greater good
according to dr fauci his desired ends
justified his dishonest means in fauci's
own telling it was politics not science
that dictated his early mask policy just
as it was politics that dictated so many
of his positions over the years
no scientific breakthrough on the
efficacy of face masks took place in the
month between vauchi's first stance and
his flip-flop
the only thing that changed was the
politics
and yet fauci couldn't bring himself to
admit it for goodness sakes i've never
had any political ideology that i've
made public i'm really just talking to
you about public health when i'm telling
you wear a mask keep social distancing
avoid crowds there's nothing political
about that that's a that's a public
health message that we know
works whatever dr fauci's expertise in
epidemiology with that exasperated plea
he proved he didn't understand the first
thing about political philosophy
how could there be nothing political
about
public policy policy that affects
hundreds of millions of people in the
united states and many more around the
world
i don't know what i'm saying that people
don't get this is not a joke
and i am not kidding
the words public and political are
synonyms
they mean the same thing
public health has a scientific aspect of
course
but it has a political aspect too
dr fauci works for the government
his job is to craft government policy
and make political decisions
he insists that what he does is merely
push policies that work but in order for
something to work it must have a purpose
a clock works when it tells time a
telephone works when it makes calls
and public policy works when it achieves
its goals
but who determines what those goals
should be
according to the traditional american
concept of self-government
we the people determine those goals
within the boundaries set by the
constitution
according to the newer progressive
conception of government those goals are
determined by a handful of largely
unaccountable bureaucrats and scientific
experts whom the people are expected
simply to follow we can halt the chain
of transmission we can do something if
we unify together we can halt this in
just a matter of a couple of weeks